ils ont planté un érable pour la paix
les représentants des différents cultes
pisciacais ont répondu présent après les
événements contre des lieux de culte de
mémoire qu'ont connu la france et les
yvelines je trouve formidable que le
maire car monsieur karl olive et répondu
à l appel à sa façon la pelle que
j'avais lancé que chaque mairie plante
un arbre
et puis on a senti les vibrations de
fraternité ici par delà les cultes d un
d autre part de la même l'absence de
religion mais la volonté de vivre
quelque chose ensemble
la partie cachée étant la racine
c'est-à-dire la filiation
quant aux deux autres partis il y a le
tronc et les branches et quand les
branches chamaillent c'est parce qu'ils
ont oublié le tronc le trempant lequel
qui les supportent et là faut dire stop
parce que la france l'autre belle
république ce n'est pas cela la france
il faut se tenir debout pour le bien
vivre fraternellement ensemble nous
sommes juifs nous sommes catholiques
nous sommes musulmans nous sommes flics
nous sommes protestants nous sommes
tolérants
nous sommes ensemble c'est au coeur du
jardin de l'olivier que l' arbre a été
planté un lieu pensé par les cultes
monothéistes et la ville de poissy en
2016 il est nécessaire je pense que nous
montrons que nous montrons que chaque
fois que quelqu'un de et est attaqué et
atteint montrer notre notre union notre
désaccord nôtres
notre fraternité doit s'exercer au
quotidien dans des petits gestes en 2018
les actes à caractère antisémite était
en hausse de 74%